[Music]
big story President Obama has invited
Mitt Romney to lunch at the White House
tomorrow yeah in a related story Romney
sent an email to all his donors with the
headings see I am headed to the White
House
just not the way I thought I would
seriously Mitt Romney is gonna meet
President Obama at the White House
tomorrow they're gonna get together and
talk things out yeah and after three
weeks of dealing with the Benghazi
scandal and the fiscal cliff Obama is
prepared to offer Romney a position in
the administration President of the
United States he's like I've made a
mistake it's all yours
I thank you many people speculate
Hillary Clinton that's not official but
she'll be right yeah a Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton is giving a lot of
interviews now and she said the person
who has had the most profound effect on
her was Nelson Mandela yeah yeah and
Bill Clinton said he relates to Nelson
Mandela because he too has been denied
freedom for decades
Hey
Starbucks is selling a new rare coffee
that costs seven dollars a cup true
seven dollars a cup you can order the
seven dollar coffee by going to
Starbucks asking for their cheapest cup
of coffee the new CEO of Yahoo was in
the news the new CEO of Yahoo gave an
interview she said that her priorities
are God family and Yahoo in that order
when reached for comment God and her
family said I think she should be
worrying more about Yahoo okay we're
fine
apples in the news Apple has fired the
manager who was responsible for the
faulty mapping app on the iPhone
they fired that guy apparently after he
was fired he asked for a letter of
recommendation and directions home
[Applause]
came back in the canoe crazy story a
wide receiver for the Chicago Bears
claims that NFL players used viagra to
give them quote an edge yeah apparently
it comes in handy when it's fourth and
inches
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
won an award for that joke that was
fantastic from the pharmaceutical
industry it was reported I thought that
was interesting it was reported today
that dr. Dre makes twice as much money
as Justin Bieber yeah mainly because of
dr. Dre's lucrative dermatology practice
now we thought that was funny because
he's a doctor
[Laughter]
hey did you hear about this
he's a doctor
dr. Dre he's a dermatologist you and me
look at here he gets a lot of money from
Botox that stuff is a gold mine I'm just
digging this hole deep intensely I was
yeah that's a rash
[Applause]
hey dr. Dre can I have some retin-a you
know got a little acne aha you got you
got poison ivy stronger they just needed
it acted outside we're back together my
friends my patented dr. Dre impression
no one does a dr. Dre impression like
Andy Richter of Norwegian German exact